[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo un
tour d'horizon de l'actualité de la
semaine dans le département
au sommaire de cette édition les
décodeurs de l'europe à montigny le
bretonneux jeudi soir plusieurs
spécialistes associatif et
institutionnel de l'union européenne
étaient présents pour répondre aux
interrogations
objectif de ce rendez-vous démêler le
vrai du faux sur les questions
européennes en reportage dans cette
édition mobilisation du parti socialiste
des yvelines en pologne en perspective
des prochaines élections à l on court
parlons europe c'est le nom de la
réunion publique organisée lundi 19
novembre en présence du député boris
vallot à l'initiative de cet événement
notre invité michel beso conseiller
municipal d'opposition à elancourt enfin
dans le reste de l'actualité retour sur
le règlement intercommunal de saint
quentin en yvelines relatif à la
publicité et sur l'inauguration de la
maison médicale du théâtre à trappes
avant de développer ses titres cette
information concernant le procès de
michel fourniret et monique olivier
devant la cour d'assises de versailles
le procureur a requis ce vendredi 16
novembre une peine de réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour l'encontre
du à l'encontre du couple après trois
jours de jugement pour l'assassinât de
farida hammiche disparu en 1988
c'est un dispositif développé par
l'association face yvelines avec les
entreprises basées dans le département
ce matin la première job academy avec
safran hélicoptère engines a été lancé
sur le site de buch les une promotion
baptisée booster pendant quatre mois
neuf par un salarié du groupe vont
accompagner neuf personnes en recherche
d'emploi sur le territoire du mantois
une aide pour redonner confiance à
apporter quelques conseils et partager
des expériences
propos recueillis par grégory canale et
l'objectif c'est qu' il soit pendant
quatre mois suivie à raison de deux
rendez vous par mois par un parrain ou
une marraine qu'ils participent à des
ateliers collectifs et qu'il soit aussi
en cas de soucis superviser encore donné
par nous en accompagnement de façon à
être le plus possible booster dans leur
dynamique de recherche d'emploi pendant
quelques années vont qu'on cesse un peu
à voir
et puis après bas pour revenir c'est
plus difficile on a du mal tout seul à
revenir sur le marché du travail change
aussi il évolue aussi et nous on
n'évolue pas avec le marché du travail
quand on est un peu à l'écart avec les
années on en a qui arrivent à savoir
faire des connaissances et puis c'est
très bien de partager dans les six mois
qui suivent ce dispositif 70 % des
filles retrouvent un emploi selon face
yvelines déchiffrer et expliquer les
politiques européennes l'objectif de la
réunion des décodeurs de l'europe à la
maison louis jouvet à montigny le
bretonneux ce jeudi 15 novembre
un événement co organisé par l'antenne
du mouvement européen de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
représentation de la commission
européenne à paris et la maison de
l'europe des yvelines
un reportage de manon varaldo selon
roues le processus de décision en europe
est il trop opaques
oui ceux qui sont pour le we luv la main
à l'instant s'il vous plaît comprendre
les enjeux de l'union européenne souvent
source de questionnement
tel est le but de la réunion organisée à
montigny le bretonneux par l'antenne de
saint quentin en yvelines du mouvement
européen
ça consiste à reprendre l'ensemble des
items qui sont diffusées dans les médias
qui pour la plupart sont relativement
négatif et qui donc vont les reprendra
par un enfant en fonction des questions
de la salle et les démonter avec des
arguments objectifs à l'appui
parmi les sujets abordés l'économie
l'agriculture ou encore l'immigration
les décodeurs de l'europe du soir sont
des membres du mouvement des jeunes
européens et un représentant de la
commission européenne
en france le système qui a été créée
pour gérer les migrations l'a été à une
époque où la migration
n'avait pas une ampleur telle que celle
qu'on a connue en 2015
c'est la raison pour laquelle à l'union
européenne aujourd'hui est en train de
préparer une révision de ce qu'on
appelle le règlement dublin c'est celui
qui organise un petit peu tout ça une
quarantaine de participants sont venus
assister à cette réunion la plupart des
européens convaincus au finalement
parlant je voyage énormément donc pour
moi les frontières ouvertes ou des pays
sans frontières évidemment c'est
extrêmement important
c'est juste naturel et s'engager pour
l'europe parce que pour moi moi l'europe
c'est un garantie de la paix armée
européenne harmonisation fiscale et
sociale ou fonctionnement des
institutions
plusieurs idées à éclaircir en vue des
élections européennes du 26 mai 2010
neuf et il n'y a pas qu'à montigny le
bretonneux comparé l'europe mais aussi à
elancourt ce sera le cas lundi 19
novembre lors d'une réunion publique à
la maison de quartier de la ville dieu
en présence du député socialiste de
boris vallot à l'initiative de cet
événement est bien notre invité michel
besson bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller municipal d'opposition
socialiste à elancourt alors avant de
parler de l'union européenne et beaucoup
ont justement la situation du parti
socialiste dans les yvelines
plus d'une centaine de militants et
d'élus ont quitté votre parti en début
d'année vous avez choisi un nouveau
premier secrétaire fédéral yvelinois le
maire de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines jean
claude husson
comment se porte le parti socialiste en
élimine alors pardonnez moi le premier
secrétaire fédéral c'est jacques
chesnais ce n'est pas jean claude husson
jean claude husson était candidat pour
être premier fédéral et jacques chesnais
qui est un autre militant de
marly-le-roi et notre premier fédéral il
n'y a aucune difficulté
ce qui est important c'est que justement
comme il y avait plusieurs candidats en
tout cas deux il y à unité du parti
socialiste maintenant dans les yvelines
et unités pour travailler pour la
renaissance du parti socialiste et pour
porter des idées nouvelles et réaffirmer
des idées qui demeure de solidarité de
construction pour tous mais comment ça
se passe concrètement très très bien
c'est un vrai bonheur c'est je suis très
sincère quand je dis ça puisque jeu
suis pas tout à fait j'ai quelques
années de militantisme derrière moi et
je retrouve ce qui avait fait la force
du parti socialiste on débat d'idées il
n'y a pas de conflit majeur de des go 2
x ou de y
et ça se passe très très bien alors ce
lundi vous organisez une réunion
publique sur l'union européenne avec la
présence du député boris vallot quel est
l'objectif de cette réunion justement
pour démontrer auprès de la population
près de des élans courteau a d'abord ça
se passe à elancourt des saint
quentinois pour l'agglomération mais
aussi pour le département des yvelines
que le parti socialiste existe toujours
et surtout pas mort mais non seulement
il existe mais il reprend les activités
qu'ils n'auraient peut-être jamais dû
abandonner de confronter les idées et de
débattre avec la population l'europe
pourquoi cette thématique
c'est une question d'actualité bien
avant de penser aux élections
européennes suffit de regarder ce qui
s'est passé hier en angleterre de ce
qu'a pu déclarer le président de la
république sur un autre sujet c'est
vraiment un sujet d'actualité
on va en parler juste après alors on l'a
vu dans le sujet sur les décodeurs de
l'europe les questions européennes ce ne
sont pas elles sont pas forcément connus
de tous qui sait que vous souhaitez
capté à travers cette réunion publique
que vous organisez lundi les jeunes les
moins jeunes alors on a vu qu'il y avait
pas beaucoup de jeunes dans le sujet
c'est inquiétant ça oui alors c'est pas
propre à l'europe et c'est pas propre
aux réunions que peuvent organiser des
partis politiques
en tout cas je suis fier que pour la
section du parti socialiste d'elancourt
nous puissions organiser cette réunion
il y à une désaffection d'une partie de
la population qui ne à notre à notre
avis c'est dommage mais il ne se sent
plus concerné par les propositions que
nous pouvons faire et comme l'a dit
l'une des intervenantes dans votre
reportage
un des grandes forces de l'europe c'est
justement pour éviter des conflits voire
des conflits majeurs et la construction
européenne concerne l'avenir et concerne
les plus jeunes donc on espère que des
jeunes viendront à notre réunion
comment vous l'expliquez vous parti
socialiste cette désaffection pour les
questions européennes alors pas pour les
questions européennes puisque le parti
socialiste par exemple dans sa
plateforme pour l'europe propose
d'étendre et d'accompagner un peu plus
les jeunes dans le cadre des projets
erasmus mais je veux dire concernant la
population les citoyens comment vous
expliquer c'est la désaffection des
citoyens pour les pressions de l'ue
pardonnez moi l'expression la machine
européenne paraît complexe a été aussi
évoquée dans le sujet précédent
peut-être la complexité peut-être aussi
parce que c'est loin
bruxelles c'est loin malgré tout et que
nous parti socialiste est long cours on
parle de l'europe à la presse en
proximité auprès de nos concitoyens au
parti socialiste comment vous saisissez
de des prochaines élections européennes
qui auront lieu le 26 mai 2019
comment vous saisissez de cette échéance
électorale pour revenir dans le jeu
politique en france
étape par étape nous avons déjà débattu
d'un projet socialiste français pour
l'europe en cohérence d'ailleurs avec
les projets des autres partis
socialistes européens que tout à chacun
peut trouver sur le site du parti
socialiste de site national une fois que
nous sommes d'accord sur les idées sur
le projet d'une base commune
nous aurons à décider de la liste des
têtes de listes dans les deux mois qui
viennent
et puis après on rentre dans la campagne
on procède tout simplement étape par
étape
emmanuel m'apprend à parler de d'un
combat d'une opposition entre
nationalistes et progressistes au parti
socialiste vous situez dans quelle
catégorie
alors nous on se situe entre l'ultra
libéralisme et le populisme puisque la
politique du gouvernement
sous l'égide du président de la
république est une politique très
libérale une politique de droite je suis
militant de gauche et que entre les deux
il peut y avoir une social démocratie
ond
on prône la solidarité le partenariat et
la connaissance de l'autre qui permet de
progresser alors vous l'avez évoqué dans
une de vos réponses le bric site le
royaume uni et l'union européenne sont
sur la voie d'un accord
les négociateurs britanniques et
européens sont parvenus à un accord ce
mardi 12 novembre des échanges entre la
première ministre theresa may et michel
barnier le négociateur engagé choisie
par la commission européenne un accord
relatif entre les relations de l'union
européenne et le du royaume uni après la
sortie du royaume uni effective le 29
mars 2019
votre regard vous en tant que socialiste
sur le brake cité ce qu'il faut un un
break 6 kt soft c'est à dire conserver
quand même des relations de libre
échange avec le royaume uni ou est ce qu
il faut un arbre etc sitcoms comme on
entend dans les médias et une sortie
radicale de du royaume uni je répondrai
tout simplement le break site
c'est-à-dire la sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne ce qui ne veut pas
dire la sortie du royaume-uni de
l'europe dans son entité géographique le
royaume-uni restera membre de l'oha eux
restera membre de l'otan il y a
d'autres partenariats qui sont en dehors
de l'europe en tant que tel ça a été une
décision le bric site à la suite d'un
référendum je tiens à le rappeler
puisque tout le monde s'en est aperçu
basé sur le mensonge basé sur le
mensonge
souvenez vous de ce que disaient ce
qu'ils voulaient sortir de l'europe
le tout est le grand n'importe quoi ce
sont les mêmes avec les mêmes arguments
dans nos extrême dans notre pays
les populistes en france mais comme en
italie comme dans l'europe de l'est qui
disent les mêmes mensonges sur l'europe
et la catastrophe assurée c'est la
dislocation de ce qui peut faire le bien
commun de tous pour travailler pour la
paix et ça c'est dommageable
le point important sur lequel on ne peut
être vigilant c'est peut-être la
question de
l'irlande du nord est qu'il n'y ait pas
une frontière entre l'irlande du nord et
le l'irlande du sud la république
d'irlande
c'est l'un des points justement sur
lequel theresa may est en train de
peut-être de trébucher en tout cas qui
paraît difficile pour elle je vous
avouerai que j'ai pas lu l'intégralité
des 590 ces quelques pages de l'accord
conclu avant-hier alors l'accord
pourrait être conclu justement pour être
effectif devrait être validé par le
parlement britannique donc affaire à
suivre dans les semaines à venir
on arrive bientôt au terme de cet
entretien un mot juste sur une idée qui
a évoqué emmanuel mâcon cette semaine
lors d'une interview sur le porte avions
charles de gaulle accordée à nos
confrères de tf1
l'armée européenne au parti socialiste
vous soutenez ce type d'idées il faut
alors l'idée en soi de l'armée
européenne ne doit pas des manuels
macron françois mitterrand avait
longuement très longuement abordé cette
idée il y avait d'ailleurs remis pu la
mise en place de corps communs entre
l'armée française et l'armée allemande
donc ça ne date pas de l'intervention du
président de la république
c'est une idée qui demeure mais il
faudrait qu emmanuel macron regarde
l'avenir d'une façon différente
peut-être que la sécurité en europe
c'est de mettre les moyens contre la
cybercriminalité puisque les états des
états étrangers nous attaquent sur notre
parti économique dans la
cybercriminalité
c'est peut-être aussi mettre des moyens
justement pour favoriser les échanges
entre jeunes notamment dans le cadre
d'erasmus et que le plus penser
peut-être
dans une vision militaire de l'armée de
grand papa et de l'armée de 14 michel
baud merci d'être venu sur notre plateau
vous allez détaillé sûrement ses idées
je le rappelle lors de cette réunion
publique lundi 19 novembre à la maison
du quartier de ville de la ville du à
elancourt en présence du député boris
vallot passer un bon week-end merci
merci et vous chaque vendredi dans
l'hebdo on revient sur les événements
passés à saint quentin en yvelines ou
dans les yvelines avec notre rubrique ça
s'est passé un voyage dans le temps
signés wilfried richy
[Musique]
les gâteaux biscuits une maladie de
son au cancer c'est le candidat qui ride
ou
la démonologie quelques ceux de ses
enfants qu'elle était trop difficile
les têtes les lignes umbro vivre et
maintenant vous voyez que le guet
télécom
tous les enfants elle se sent bien
pendant trois semaines ses enfants
biélorusses tous touchés par le nuage de
tchernobyl ont vécu en france en ville
nouvelle pour la plupart entre
hébergement dans des familles est sorti
c'est une expérience souvent unique pour
ces enfants de milieu modeste aux
situations familiales parfois difficile
une façon d'échapper à une vie où la
catastrophe nucléaire laisse encore des
traces même si comme le dit rina on n'en
parle plus trop génial score maintenant
cela fait dix ans
appuyé par des échanges et nous n'aime
pas en parler et n'en parle pas vraiment
cela reste pourtant un vrai problème
avec notre gouvernement n'aide pas le
secteur humanitaire
si on est venu et plusieurs autres
groupes à l'étranger c'est que les gens
de france par exemple nous aide c'est
pour cela que nous sommes ici
mais ces enfants vivent
vie de leurs trois semaines ici un peu
comme un conte de feuilles c'est une
parenthèse dans leur vie et pour
certains
on essaie de leur expliquer aussi que
même s'il ya tout dans les magasins on
peut pas forcément tous leur acheter on
a de plus en plus de raison d'être parce
qu'en fait les conséquences médicales de
tchernobyl
quand voit que le
le bout de l'île de liesberg les
les semis sont en augmentation le retour
à la maison
hamon
[Musique]
passons tout de suite le résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
et tout d'abord cette information les
douaniers de paris ouest ont saisi 800
cartouches de cigarettes lundi 12
novembre
cela fait suite à un contrôle au péage
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines aux
alentours de 3 heures du matin valeur
totale de la marchandise 66 1400 euros
la personne en infraction s'expose à une
lourde amende pouvant atteindre jusqu'à
5 fois le prix légal de la marchandise
comment encadrer la publicité urbaine
dans une agglomération de plus de trente
deux cent trente mille habitants c'est
la question à laquelle saint quentin en
yvelines essaye de répondre depuis le
mois d'octobre des orientations été
présenté officiellement lundi soir lors
d'une réunion publique
elle pourrait être applicable dès 2020
et harmonisée sur les douze communes du
territoire un reportage de michael et
demi d'euros et grégory canal et la
publicité urbaine au coeur d'une réunion
publique ce lundi 12 novembre saint
quentin en yvelines a présenté à cette
occasion ses premiers travaux sur son
futur règlement local de publicité
intercommunale c'est un texte important
pour le cadre de vie des habitants et
donc je devais aussi concerté l'ensemble
des acteurs que ce soit les habitants
les acteurs économiques ou les acteurs
qui milite pour la protection de
l'environnement pour essayer d'avoir un
texte finalement qui soit équilibrée et
qui convienne à tout le monde
plusieurs axes ont été proposées au
cours de cette soirée pour encadrer
cette publicité urbaine à l'horizon 2020
les objectifs sont clairs réduire le
format publicitaire sur le territoire
avec la proposition qui est faite
de passer de 12 m² à 8 mètres carrés
pour ce qui concerne la publicité c'est
une proposition qui est en cours de
discussion c'est aussi la volonté
d'imposer des règles de densité qui
seraient plus stricts que la
réglementation nationale
malgré ces propositions certains
habitants présents dans la salle reste
sceptique sur ce futur règlement ils ont
pu faire part de leurs inquiétudes
très clairement notre plus grosse
crainte et puis on l'a vu ce soir il ya
eu beaucoup de commentaires là dessus
c'est les écrans numériques qui est un
nouveau type de dispositif publicitaire
très agressif et énergivore en plus dont
l'implantation apparemment et tourner
quand même sur beaucoup de zones sur
l'agglomération
d'autant plus que les dimensions même si
on va à les réduire pour tout ce qui est
affichage a dû 12 m par du 8 mètres
carrés
la cen sad sous-tend qu'on va pouvoir
implanter des écrans numériques de 8
mètres carrés disque est énormissime les
dossiers de concertation sont
disponibles dans l'es12 mairies de
l'agglomération vous avez jusqu'au 1er
semestre 2010 9 pour donner votre avis
elle est ouverte depuis le mois de mars
2018 mais elle a été inaugurée ce mardi
13 novembre
la maison de santé du théâtre attrapé
composé de 14 professionnels médicaux
une opportunité pour la commune
d'augmenter le nombre de médecins en
reportage un pôle médical de 285 mètres
carrés répartis sur 3 zones c'est la
nouvelle maison de santé du théâtre de
trappes médecins généralistes sages
femmes infirmières ostéopathe
psychologue orthophoniste un projet
collectif et un travail collaboratif
nous parlons rencontre par nos échanges
ne fait pas d'eux
de savoir ce que fait ce que font les
autres et cetera on a une orientation
beaucoup plus efficace ça doit partir
des professionnels et les professionnels
à partir du moment où ils ont un projet
que ce soit dans une maison de santé ou
par une coordination entre eux mais la
rs doit être capable de les accompagner
c'est aussi ça le dialogue entre tous
les professionnels de santé médecins
infirmières ostéopathe sages-femmes
psychologue qui permet une prise en
charge globale des patients et c'est ça
que nous voulons encourager coût total
de cette maison de santé près d'un
million d'euros avec un financement de
l' agence régionale de santé de l'ue rps
hauteur de 350 mille euros une
subvention de la région ile-de-france de
260 milles euros
ça correspond à une volonté de la région
de la présidente de la région valérie
pécresse est bien de lutter contre les
déserts médicaux et on est ici dans une
ville qui est l'une des plus carencée en
termes de médecins généralistes alors
naturellement il est important de
soutenir ce type de structure et avec
encore une fois un montant très
importante pour la ville de trappes
classé en zone d'intervention
prioritaire par la rs c'est une
opportunité d'augmenter l'offre de soins
sur la commune ont cette maison de santé
qui je viens d'apprendre la maintenant
représente 14 praticiens c'est un pôle
essentiel pour notre ville d'autres
pièces vont être aménagés pour pouvoir
accueillir de nouveaux spécialistes et
des internes en médecine dans cette
nouvelle maison de santé du sport la
fédération française de gymnastique et
le club de gymnastique rythmique
d'elancourt mans repas organisé une
compétition régionale samedi 17 et
dimanche 18 novembre au palais des
sports
700 gymnastes viendront s'affronter et
tenter de se qualifier pour l'étape
suivante pour mener au championnat de
france
marylène iapichino a assisté à un
entraînement regardez un des 3 4
l'entraînement est intensif pour les
jeunes gymnastes ont compétition du club
de gymnastique rythmique d'elancourt
maurepas 19 heures d'entraînement par
semaine auxquels s'ajoutent des stages
pendant les vacances scolaires
chaque séance commence par une bonne
heure d'échauffement où des 3 4 les
filles passent ensuite aux engins pour
les compétitions chaque gymnaste prépare
un enchaînement 2 minutes 30 avec un
engin imposé par la fédération c'est un
enchaînement qu'est entraîneurs
préparent quand on cherche les musiques
la terre
monteyne chinois ont complet musique
c'est énorme travail et après on
travaille ça pour plupart et pour
compétition les filles se donnent à fond
pour ce sport mêlant la technique la
souplesse et l'artistique bananarama
vais emmener voir un gala de gym ici et
puis j'ai adoré du coup bas
en effet bas c'était le fait de pouvoir
essayer de me dépasser et faire une
possible le plus pour évoluer cd d'être
ban d'être mieux placé fait d'aimer
pointe et direct tony claude auxerre et
à cers la professeur russe fait du
repérage dès le plus jeune âge les
petites semaines aux entraînements des
plus grandes qui leur montre la voie
plus on commence tôt et plus on se plie
aux règles et plus c'est facile
en fait pour travailler la souplesse
pour travailler la technique c'est des
bases qu'il faut acquérir très vite
parce que l'âge est là c'est une
carrière à une carrière qui s'arrêtent
très tôt une méthode qui porte ses
fruits morgan a fait partie de l'équipe
de france sa carrière de gymnaste de
haut niveau terminé elle aime revenir
dans son club de coeur
donner un coup de main à son ancien
coach
[Musique]
les vidéo clubs font face à la
révolution numérique vous savez ces
boutiques où vous pouvez louer des films
cassette vidéo dvd ou blu ray mais
comment se portent les enseignes face
aux géants du numérique direction le
magasin vidéosphère à paris un reportage
de nos confrères de via dans paris
vidéosphère est l'un des derniers vidéo
club de paris en plein coeur du vème
arrondissement
ce magasin old school ou des dvd blu ray
mais également des cassettes vhs
ouvert depuis près de 25 ans par un
passionné de cinéma
ce vidéo club compte près de 60 mille
références malgré un déménagement il ya
quelques mois pour des raisons
économiques
le propriétaire continue de croire à
l'avenir de son vidéo club maintenant
économiquement alors c'est une niche
parce qu'on a un catalogue est énorme
avec de nombreux films introuvables
qu'on ne peut pas trouver en dvd ou
alors même des dvd qu'on a qui sont
maintenant introuvable et même peu sur
le téléchargement sur internet
on va pas forcément les trouver
l'authenticité du vidéo club passe par
l'incontournable location de vhs ou
20000 cassettes sont disponibles mais si
le vinyle redevient à la mode de nos
jours le propriétaire a du mal à
imaginer la même destinée pour la vhs
moi j'y crois pas trop
maintenant c'est vrai qu'on a quelques
clients mais c'est vraiment une
exception de personnes qui préfèrent
voir le film en vhs plutôt qu'en dvd
dans l'histoire de grains c'est plus
authentique mais moi personnellement je
pense pas à l'époque de la révolution
numérique et de netflix
le vidéo club se met en mode survie
vidéosphère s'appuie sur ses clients
fidèles notamment parce qu'il est
difficile d'attirer nouvelle clientèle
et ce malgré l'intérêt des dvd pour
autant henri moissan pense que les vidéo
clubs ont encore leur place dans les
rues parisiennes
moi je suis pas du tout content rené
fixe contre les bucks contre le
téléchargement mais je suppose qu'il ya
la place pour tout le monde c'est une
autre
anou démarche d'aller au vidéo club que
de regarder un film sur netflix et de
démarches sont bonnes en 2018 seulement
quatre vidéos clubs sont encore ouverts
dans la capitale
et avant de se quitter regarder cette
carte des lieux dans le sud yvelines où
des mobilisations j les jeunes sont
prévues des mouvements sur la nationale
10 la nationale 12 ou encore la 10 pour
dénoncer la fiscalité sur le carburant
des répercussions sur la circulation
pourrait avoir lieu sur les principaux
axes du département
les services de la préfecture et les
forces de l'ordre seront mobilisés pour
encadrer ces manifestations c'est la fin
de ce numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo merci de
nous avoir suivis retour de
l'information à 18 heures lundi dans le
journal
d'ici là passez un excellent week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]